To test this architecture
on real devices,
let's use WEBPAGETEST to take
a look at the weather app that
you're going to be building
throughout this course.
First, let's try using a Nexus 5
on a typical cable connection.
We did a lot of work to
optimize the app, but
it still takes 1.1 seconds until
there's anything on screen.
And it takes 1.9 seconds to
completely render the page.
Thanks to service workers, a repeat
visit achieves it's first meaningful
paint after only 0.3 seconds and
is finished rendering at 0.6 seconds.
What about on a slower connection?
Let's try using a Nexus 5
on a typical 3G connection.
The first time to meaningful
paint is now three seconds, and
it took five seconds until
everything is finished rendering.
Here's where we really see
the performance improvements of
service workers.
A repeat visit with service workers
enabled takes only 0.3 seconds for
the first meaningful paint and
0.5 seconds until it's finish rendering.
On a 3G connection
using service workers,
we got a ten x performance boost.
The visual complete event went
from 5 seconds to 0.5 seconds.
If you have users on Edge,
the results are even more drastic.
Instead of taking 13 seconds
to complete rendering,
everything is now rendered
in 0.8 seconds, nice.